hi my name is Brendan Byrnes I'm a
software engineer on the
Tanner's container clusters and the
Cooper Nettie's project so you may have
heard of containers recently they've
been popularized by the docker project
although they've been in existence for
quite a long time and we've been using
them at Google for a while what I really
want to show you today is how containers
enable you to build applications that
are modular scalable and portable across
a variety of platforms and in particular
how container cluster managers like
Cooper Nettie's enable you to build
robust applications that look and feel
the same whether they're on a public
cloud a private cloud or even physical
infrastructure in order to show you this
I'm going to show you an application
running in Coober Nettie's on two
platforms different public cloud
provider as well as the Google cloud
platform so let's jump right in now here
is my application it's a simple
three-tier application I have a
replicated set of front ends I have a
Redis right storage for for writing my
data and I have some read replicas for
adding extra capability for people who
are simply reading the data that I've
stored inside of Redis and take a look
at what I'm actually implementing it's a
really simple guestbook here it allows
me to enter messages like I really hope
this hope this demo goes well submit
them and they're stored into Redis and
so what I what I'm interested in showing
you though is how this application which
is running on a different cloud provider
can look and feel exactly the same when
it's running on the Google cloud
platform because we're using the same
container cluster infrastructure on both
places so in order to do that I'm going
to go over to a different instance of
Coober Nettie's running inside of Google
container engine so now I'm in my
container cluster or my container engine
cluster and I'm going to turn on my
application so I'm going to go to my
command line and run a script that
encapsulates a number of commands to
Coober Nettie's and what's important to
note is that exactly the same
declarative configuration information
that defined my application when it was
running on a different public cloud now
is used to define my application running
inside a container engine I've made
exactly no changes and that's because
the kokuboro Nettie's cluster manager is
this abstraction layer that isolates me
for
the specifics of the virtual machines
where I'm running and I focus really on
my application containers all right so
now that the guest book is up and
running let's go over to the visualizer
so now you see the Cooper Nettie's user
interface running on Google container
engine and you can see that there is
really no difference between the
experience on another cloud provider and
on container engine because we're
interfacing with the coup benetti's
layer in fact the only difference that
you're going to see is that the host
names here are different and that's of
course just because we're running on a
different cloud provider i still have my
three front ends i still have my mast
read master and right master and i still
have my read replicas now communities
doesn't just provide a uniform interface
to your application it actually provides
some robust management features that
make your application more reliable and
easier to scale and I want to
demonstrate a few of these things for
you first by simulating a failure of
your application and then by showing you
how you might scale up or scale down the
number of front ends so to simulate a
failure I'm going to go to my guestbook
here and I'm going to go hop over to my
terminal and show you this is the Miss
is the virtual machine that's actually
running that container and what you can
see the front end container image it's
running right here it's been up for nine
minutes now what I'm going to do here is
I'm going to kill that container to
simulate a failure I'm going to go back
to my web browser and we hit reload and
of course the web page is unavailable
because I just killed it now hopefully
you're using a load balancer and now I
hit reload and you see that the web page
immediately came back and if we go back
to the terminal and I run that PS
command again you'll now see that my
front end has been up for 10 seconds and
the reason that it did that is because
Cooper Nettie's is constantly monitoring
your application and ensuring that your
desired state that your application is
up and running matches the current state
and if it doesn't for example your
application crashed it takes actions to
fix the problem now another common
activity the developers want to do is to
scale their application maybe it's to
scale down during the evening when
there's less traffic or maybe it's to
scale up in response to some sort of
event maybe social media has caught
ahead of your startup you can go back to
our user interface you can see here we
have three front ends well what if we
want to make that four front ends let's
go back to the terminal and say
use our COO benetti's command-line tool
we're going to resize the replication
controller that's the object that is
responsible for managing these replicas
our front-end controller and we're gonna
set replicas to size for now this is
issued an API call out to the kuru
Nettie's master and it's creating a
replica then we go back over to our
dashboard and we reload the dashboard
and you can see here now that we have
for front-end replicas now likewise we
can scale downward if we want to have
fewer containers running either to save
costs or to make room for some other
application we'll just issue the same
command this time we'll set replicas to
one and if we go back to our dashboard
again you'll see that there's a single
replica there okay so that's it for the
demo I hope I've shown you how
containers and container cluster
managers like Cooper Nettie's enable you
to build an application that's
homogeneous across a wide variety of
platforms from public clouds to private
clouds to physical infrastructure and
the Google cloud platform as well I hope
I've also shown you how the cluster
management system provides more
robustness for your application and
scalability as well thank you